- Oh my--
- Ugh.
- Oh!
- Nat, what do you know about childbirth?
What do you know about childbirth?
- Well--
- A whole lot actually,
I've studied it in school.
- We're here because of it.
- I've witnessed a Kardashian birth.
- How was the Kardashian birth?
- Well it just happens
like regular human birth.
- Have you ever seen an animal being born?
- Oh no.
- Would you be interested in seeing?
- Yes.
- Hold this mic.
- I would like to do.
- I would love to see that.
- You're gonna show us a
child being born right?
- Yeah, well an animal child.
- Are you gonna give me
some facts about it also?
- Nah.
- I trust you 0%
- Yeah you should not at all.
- It's a giraffe birth.
Right, should we narrate?
- Okay so there's a giraffe, lots of--
Oh my God!
Okay!
- Thats a giraffe being born.
Ah!
- Oh my gosh there's a thing
coming out of the giraffes butt hole.
- Ah! It is just hanging there.
- The mother giraffe is standing up
which is to be applauded.
- I hear some strange sounds.
- It's dangling, it's falling out, it's--
- Oh!
- Oh my gosh.
- [DNCE] Oh!
- Oh!
- What is that?
Is that the head?
- It's an amazing thing.
- Hey, hey!
- Puff Daddy just yelled at us.
We gotta keep it down.
- Elephant?
- Elephant, here we go.
- Now how many times have you seen this?
- Many.
- Yeah.
- Oh no! And the balloon thing.
- Oh!
- Oh no!
- That is horrible.
- Oh!
- That's so much blood!
(gagging)
- You can not watch that.
- Oh!
- Oh my gosh.
- Ah.
- Was that poop?
- It's so pretty.
- That is heavy.
- That's how babies are made.
- That's not exactly how
I would've expected it.
- Not like the Kardashian birth.
- Little different.
- Well, wasn't so bad right?
- It was pretty bad.
- Do you feel closer to me?
- Yeah, we could talk about stuff.
- Yeah.
- Have you seen videos of seahorses?
Have you seen videos of them having birth?
This is really beautiful though,
this is different.
I think you're gonna be amazed.
- Oh my God!
Oh my God!
- Yeah I know.
- This is so good, this
should be in the video.
Just shooting them out repeatedly.
- You have to see this.
- This is unbelievable, I've
never seen anything like this.
I came here to show you animal childbirth,
you showed me one.
- Well yeah.
- Shawn thanks so much man.
- I appreciate it, thank you.
- Pleasure.
Alright.